my name is might you see I'm on the
faculty at the University of
Pennsylvania's Wharton School that
business school it's been my privilege
to participate in the annual meeting of
the world economic forum here in Davos
this week and my observation about the
state of the world where we're going to
next five to ten years is that as
expressed by many people here this week
the opportunities are large for the
private sector and public sector to work
actively together that means many things
of course including a willingness of a
part of people in the private sector to
take a stint in government to take a
public act of public service our role of
that kind or even if not that for people
in the private sector to become involved
in public service some of the companies
who have been active this week in Davos
have also on their own come active in
recovery from the catastrophic
developments in Haiti to form a public
service obviously and the theme that
strikes me is maybe one of the most
important issues of this current world
economic mom's annual event is that the
potential is enormous for that public
sector and the private sector to work
together to address the big problems
that we face education health
catastrophes of one kind or another and
I think just looking forward next five
to ten years I think we're going to see
more public-private partnerships are
going to see more people moving from the
private sector into the public sector
and I think we're going to see a lot of
people in the public sector and active
dialogue with people in private industry
on how to solve the problems that we all
face as the global community thank you
very much